welcome back everybody um this is a
panel discussion talking about
statistical agencies official statistics
where where are we going with our
confidentiality and privacy I'm very
pleased that John agreed to be on the
panel because he was on the Tuesday
panel and he agreed to come back for the
Thursday panel so John about from the US
Census Bureau and York Dressler from the
IAB number Germany and broker Crocker I
can't even the University of Maryland my
time I ain't be lots of affiliation so I
sort of put together a few sort of
preliminary questions just to focus the
conversation but of course their
panelists are free to bring up any other
issues that they would like to discuss
but the my sort of motivating questions
were about the challenges and the
obstacles for statistical agencies to
consider you know more formal privacy
models and of course the agencies are
well grounded in disclosure limitation
approaches which are basically based on
the risk of re-identification and do we
need to continue with these sort of
common practices common disclosure
limitation practices that are mostly on
the whole non perturbative methods for
protecting the data do we need to still
think about disclosure risks in terms of
linkage attacks or risk identification
or singling out which we heard the other
day how do we convince the statistical
agencies and the user community to
accept perturbation so this is not a you
know a very common thing and a very big
obstacle in statistical agencies to
start actually changing the data after
they worked so hard to collect it and to
have such good data and then we go and
mess it up so it's a a very a big
problem and then of course the the issue
of the current legislation which is
about re re identification and do we
need to think about lobbying our
legislation
you know the government to that this is
really there's no way you can avoid
reaiiy denta fication in this digital
age when everybody has got fingerprints
all over the internet and and maybe we
should start moving towards you know
something more similar to the notion of
differential privacy and inferential
disclosure and not try and guarantee
that every single person in our database
can't be reaiiy denta fide because
that's hopeless but so those are sort of
the motivating questions and I'm the
moderator so I'm gonna let the panelists
speak and of course you're free to bring
up any other topics
Yeah right this is this was fun and it's
even more fun since John is the only one
really and your is that a real
statistically can shed some light on the
discussions internally what I thought
might be useful just you alluded to this
a little bit this morning but to give
you a little bit of context from the
European perspective which what struck
me listening to this week's discussions
and the group came and discussions on
the side is that in aside from the
Scandinavian countries to which you say
something in a moment but you know
Central European countries I take a
Germany which we know best so I know
best the discussion is quite different
because we do not have a tradition of
microdata being out in a public use file
fashion right so there's no - there is
no criminal record data that you know
that you have look up housing prices you
can't there's a lot of things voting
records I mean every time I tell someone
at home that you can look up voting
records see they're falling off that
chair it's inconceivable that that fits
in the public space and so in so with
the statistical agencies and other
program agencies in many of these
countries countries are trying to do
right now is to to push a little bit the
data into a more user accessible space
but that meaning they're pushing them
into a
and in in that still and I mean so in
that sense you know that is still the
majority of the discussion and
interestingly I have seen very little
trying to figure out how could we go
beyond there is a big discussion on how
to scale that process right so the idea
the research data center asked right now
about you know 1,200 users and roughly
700 projects and and they have every
month about a thousand outputs they try
to review and they have every day one
person working on a country how about
was right that sort of the scale in
which they operate and alright and and
in right now they're dealing with about
80% of these output control requests
automatically through a system that sort
of but those are outputs that are used
internally for further thinking about
the projects and discussion outside
publications are all review at menu but
so anyway that's that that's the
bottleneck they see but but most of this
question goes in that direction and so
your policy questions are very difficult
to answer in that space because the
mindset is incomplete
I checked in with a couple of other
statistical agencies that I know a
little better and you know the comment I
got from Belgium to your question was
like oh my god this is so far beyond
anything we can currently think about we
have no resources to even understand
what that would mean one and quite
different in Canada they have more
resources and follow more closely what
the US does but they - I mean they are
thinking of I mean I guess they follow
quite closely what happens with respect
to the census and that might be the
first place maybe right but in general
they too have over the last couple of
years pushed much more towards the use
of administrative data in that context
and and so last sentence I wanted wanted
to say with the administrative data
Jamia in many contexts that what I've
seen if you look at the statues with
which these administrative data can be
used they are often so closely tied to a
policy case for which the admin data
were collected right so you need like
just as a case study if I want to do
some methods research on data on the
unemployment I'm sorry on the wage
records that the IAB has for research
purposes I have to show to the Ministry
of Labor a clear labor market research
context and reason in order to get
access to the data right even for an
internal project right so there is
already a loop and project review
similar to what you would see in an RTC
that we can let just let it not get
around and if I want to do a method
study to sort of you know test some
statistical methods or what have you
unless it's tied to a labor market
question and I can demonstrate that it
wouldn't help labor market policy I
don't get access to this so they they
there is there a restriction that that
would make it very unlikely any time
soon that these data could ever be
outside the research data center to
begin with
intro thank you yuck okay yeah so what I
found very very funny and and
enlightening yesterday over lunch when
we had these the the meeting with Chan
somebody asked do you get any useful
inputs from other statistical agencies
in other countries about differential
privacy and I think chance answer was
pretty clear that he said no they are
all coming to me and I mean that's
that's exactly the situation we are in I
think that currently I feel all other
statistical agencies at least the ones I
know about they basically would say
right now let's see what happens at the
census and then you know we'll see what
we will do about it
all right so they are very passive I
mean they I think a lot there's a lot of
interest everybody's following what's
going on here but it's not like there's
real active research in other
statistical agencies and I think what's
what's also important in this context I
think is always to keep in mind that all
these discussions about privacy
confidentiality they are so much
influenced by the cultural background of
the different countries and that's what
Fraga already alluded to when she
mentioned the Scandinavian countries
because in the Scandinavian countries
basically you can always have all the
data and nobody cares it's really like
you know they it's they always love when
they hear what other statistical
agencies are doing even the small things
that happen in Europe at other
statistical agencies because they say
you know why do you care I mean
everybody can have our data in our
country and and and there's no I mean
nobody is really concerned about it they
just don't feel like this is problematic
in any way and if you're in such a
situation of course then to them
this idea of you know we need to alter
everything and we you know need to
infuse noise and all that it seems just
not a necessary thing to to even think
about and and I mean and think that this
has important consequences and in
Germany particularly we also have a
special situation in terms of research
access so there's a differentiation even
in the law between whether it's public
use data or whether it's data that
should only be used by scientific
researchers so if a scientific
researcher asked for access the only
thing that needs to be ensured is so we
there's a differentiation in the law
between what do they call it they call
it absolutely anonymous whatever that's
supposed to mean I don't think any data
can ever be absolutely anonymous but
that's the one thing so this would be
for the general public and then there's
something called de-facto anonymous
which means and I think that's an
interesting interpretation it basically
is always interpreted like this that the
amount of effort that would be necessary
to identify someone in the database or
learn something about someone the
database is higher than the gains you
get in terms of the information that you
learn now about that individual and and
the argument then is you know in many of
these data sets this information that is
in there is really not that interesting
in and of itself so in the sense if you
think about all these efforts that would
be necessary to run these kind of
reconstruction attacks and then you
don't learn too much the idea is you
know there's there's just an imbalance
between the two and so in that sense we
don't even need to think about these
situations but then it comes back to and
I think that's also important it comes
back to the question how sensitive is my
data because I think with differential
privacy in general
this question is no longer the the
relevant question because we just ensure
that you know whatever the question is
it won't
differ too much whether the the unit is
in the database or not it's not about
how sensitive is that question that is
answered it's just it holds in general
right whereas and with this specific
definition we are back in the situation
where we should think about is that
sensitive information or not or how
sensitive is that information which I
think changes a little bit the way we
think about that problem but
nevertheless I mean there's there's a
lot of interest in differential privacy
and I think one one thing that I also
wanted to touch on a little bit because
it's one of the the questions that
Natalie raised in terms of you know what
is necessary that the users would accept
preserved data and I think I mean from
my own experience I did a lot of work on
synthetic data and channel so the the
ideas related to Jon Rubin that have
been mentioned a while ago and in some
of the talks today in yesterday and the
basic thing is that users will not
accept the data as long as they don't
know what the impacts of the
perturbation are and it's not like I
don't think it even helps if you show
them some results so this is what is
generally done with synthetic data you
would say you know we run a couple of
regressions and a couple of analysis and
say you know this is what you have
gotten from the original data this is
what you get from the synthetic data
it's close so my synthetic data is
probably good still nobody would use the
data because they say but how do I know
that my analysis I'm interested in how
do I know that this one is really close
to the one I would have gotten from the
original data and so I think it's very
important or in my view at least an
important direction and astronaut to
that too is that we need to think about
that we can make sure that we always
know what are the exact impacts for a
specific type of analysis based on the
noisy data so that I know you know will
the results be biased and if yes how
much can I correct for that and can i
quantify the amount of error and not in
terms of you know this is the maximum
error that I might expect but really
what is the the amount of error for this
specific type of analysis I think this
would be important things to make that
more appealing to users of the tail
I'd remind you that I'm speaking for
myself so I want to make a couple of
very quick points and then I know you
guys have lots of questions first every
major product from the US Census Bureau
uses perturbative methods and has for
decades I'm not sure why that isn't well
understood but perhaps it's because we
wish to distinguish between
perturbations that can be written down
with probability laws and perturbations
that can't but because we don't reveal
all the way in which the complimentary
suppression is done in standard
disclosure limitation systems from the
point of view of the user that is random
and therefore virtually every
statistical product released by every
National Statistical Office in the world
uses perturbative methods that's point
one point two is sort of what urug was
saying it is the case that many of the
data products that are produced by
statistical agencies are about things
that there's a widespread view are
important for society they are important
for good government and for the
well-being of the people for whom the
statistics were collected and therefore
the good actors in this in the society
do not demonstrate that those methods
are in fact unsafe now that is starting
to change and one of the reasons why we
didn't ourselves inside the Census
Bureau is because it was clear to us
that if we didn't we were just going to
be waiting for what happened this week
to ABS to happen to us somebody outside
it was a good actor who did it for abs
they did it on the simulated data set
and then showed that the simulated data
set you could recover the real records
so there's a role for good actors in
helping the statistical agencies
understand that the mathematical basis
for suppression is a subtraction attack
and a subtraction attack is a special
case of a reconstruction attack
now the tables are vulnerable to other
kinds of reconstruction attacks and if
they are sufficiently detailed those
reconstruction attacks can be incredibly
accurate images of the underlying data
those are sort of things that I think
the Statistical agencies need to admit
right now and they need to say the
perturbative method that we have relied
on the most primary and complementary
suppression is perturbative because we
can't tell you how to correct the biases
and the biases matter there's a very
widely used data set published by
another statistical agency in the United
States where more than half of the value
of the underlying entities is suppressed
by the combination of primary and
complementary suppression and
researchers routinely use the rest of it
as if that was somehow missing at random
so the agencies are speaking for myself
the agencies have an obligation to their
community to come clean about what
statistical disclosure limitation
actually does and to use methods that
allow external consumers of the data to
be confident that the data can be
meaningful and speak to the hypotheses
we have to stop pretending that we did
nothing but little light touch scrubbing
around the edges and let me know that is
often true but it's far from always true
so in exchange for the good actor not
attacking the statistical agencies
databases the statistical agency should
own up to the vulnerability now we don't
have a solution for everything so we
need a way to collaborate on developing
more solutions and I think weeks like
this on this whole semester-long program
there aren't an enormous step forward I
believe that while it is an important
step in changing the way statistical
agencies behave that the Census Bureau
is going to apply differential privacy
the 2020 census that it's not the heroic
act that some people think it was a
necessary response
to a vulnerability and if somebody like
me had walked in and peered into the IT
system at the Census Bureau and said
that crypto was safe in 1990 but it's
not safe now
the only response would have been to
close off the system it was on update
the crypto that's why we do the security
scans we did a security scan of our
disclosure of limitation procedures it
revealed a vulnerability and we adopted
the best available technology a decade
from now I'm certain that this will not
be the best available technology not the
principle but the bit specific
algorithms so the deal oughta be come
clean about the limitations of
traditional disclosure limitation and
make a good-faith effort to continue to
protect the products appropriately
that's that's all I wanted to say by way
of background
great okay let's open the floor so Frank
you mentioned the taiyi you touched upon
the sort of review process that happens
but researchers coming to a research
data facility with questions they want
to ask is it the data and my question is
do we anticipate formal privacy methods
making that review process easier or
more difficult so at first you would
like to think it would make it easier
because you have this you don't need to
review the disclosure limitation methods
the outputs in the in the don't need to
scrutinize them in the in the same way
on the other hand it forces you to
confront this difficult social choice
question about the value of the question
being asked against the amount of the
budget being consumed and I'm just
curious where you know is to kind of see
this in the in the near term and the
long term yeah I think um the the
interesting point is where does that
conversation happen right and this is
not this could this can't this wouldn't
be a choice that has any effect if the
statistical agency or the subsidiary
that we are would make it would not make
a difference at all the place where the
change would need to happen is the
legislation around the collection of the
wage records in similar administrative
data because the the
[Music]
the paragraphs realize meaningless you
know so anyway but but they they they
they clearly specify that that these
data can be stored and used for
scientific purposes but only with this
specific use case right in someone
mentioned that earlier you know that GDP
are not surprisingly you know highly
drafted by German have some of that
spirit it's all sort of use case related
I mean in and so I think this can be an
interesting discussion but it's it's
like a discussion we would need to have
with someone completely different it's
not what maybe we are the statistical
agencies with you know legislators on on
these metadata but but that but that's
the place where the problem hangs you
know it's one thing that you said you
and I think that's where this formal
guarantee actually holds great promise
you said while the sensitivity depends
on a data item I know Colin still here
but she would say well it also depends
on the use case it was you can specify
that for every single item because in a
different context it might be perceived
was in another you know but but that's
not evaluated they're sensitive for this
the only goal is like what are you doing
with it and will it help
on your timeframe question disclosure on
the outputs we so the ones that hold the
data and responsible for that yes we
review for the disclosure and the output
but but they have they are responsible
for doing so and they do that I mean
that's why I mentioned these numbers so
that you get a sense of scale right I
mean we are but but a lot given the
small size of the agency but the the the
Ministry of Labor who makes the decision
whether data can be used or not right
they have an umbrella trust to the to us
that we do the disclosure control
so these are two different steps things
into your timeframe in mind in order to
change that legislation it takes time
yeah that's
so I just wanted to ask John so I never
considered self-suppression to be a
perturbative method because that's not
actually changing it's just you know
deleting information so it's interesting
and but it is true that you know the
Census Bureau has been doing record
swapping now that is actually altering
the data and a very perturbative method
although I'm sure they're not doing very
much of it what do you say about your
complimentary suppression algorithms so
I'm I have a table and they're probably
the whole table is gonna be zero but I
am deleting the the values in the cell
I'm not actually adding noise or
altering them in any ways you modify the
distribution of the data from the point
of view of the user according to a
randomness that you induced not the not
the data generating process I think that
John Freedman its example yesterday
illustrates this very well that because
of the cell suppression they got a very
different view about the population a
lot that's true I mean we yes but that
to me that's so the source of the
randomness the source of the randomness
is in the algorithm and the
secretiveness about how the algorithm
was applied but from the point of view
of the user how is that any different
for any other non ignore Balma singh
data mechanism i think that sorry i
think what you said in your statement
and just now i think if we think of ways
to convey I feel like that that's one
big missing piece right to demonstrate
and we've discussed this at length
you know before to demonstrate with the
existing set false conclusion that might
have been made or you
missing if I mean it's just it's the
teasing apart that and survived
ethnologist we always try to do you know
put a value on all these arrow sources
that go in there largely ignore it
always the focus on sampling error but
you know it's all kind and and I mean
one problem of course is that stuff is
still there even with the added notice
but but it could help to create a level
of comfort that some information is
still better than not information today
I do I do feel like that some of these
discussions go sideways because you are
purely talking about the published
tables right and you know ended yeah
anyway this is a question for John you
you were talking about the comparison
between the presentation of differential
privacy and the perturbation of
previously there's a comparison because
the previous techniques are not openly
available and so I guess sort of a
question be you know if you guys had
simply secretly implemented differential
privacy not told anyone about it
do you think people would complain Lance
I'm trying to point 1dp my answer let's
just say that at every single first
presentation one of the options openly
considered and discussed was not to talk
about this in public so it is it is a
view that
sort of like the security of your of
your cyber system because we can't get
hard proofs that you set a cyber system
up securely we have to use best
practices if you treat this like best
practice then you might say well it's
been best practice in disclosure
limitation to do it and just tell the
users that you've done it and let them I
think this is fundamentally different
and that this gets its strength from the
ability of the users to confirm that you
did that that's why you release the code
we're still struggling you should help
us with this we're still struggling
about what the kinds of proofs of
execution we can release when we release
the code so that your belief that we
actually run ran we actually have built
in some DP tests to make sure the people
we gave the code to ran it but that so
but what if you can establish that your
declaration is sufficiently trustworthy
that you did do this then then it can be
verified that the quantitative guarantee
that comes with DP is reflected in these
data and then it is best practice at
that point to say I'm going to forget
about it I'm not going to ever worry
again about whether this particular
product is less safe than when I
released it which is not the case for
the historical systems you keep paying
attention to them for quite some time
we are income and the fine thing is you
could also do that the other way around
right it's not about it's not only about
keeping secret how you protected the
data but sometimes there are discussions
whether it would be sufficient if you
publish results say a scatterplot
or regression results that nobody really
knows anyway how to really figure out
what the risks are there and just right
underneath it no data have been altered
sufficiently to protect the information
but don't do anything at all it's just
this perceived protection that happened
that people would not even think about
you know this is still the real data
right I can't imagine the people who go
around breaking things for fun wouldn't
play with that and detect that you had
in fact done nothing and and embarrass
you significantly
not to mention compromise the privacy of
the people in the data set right sure I
mean if you would then really go back
and yeah I it was just yeah well one
thing following up on what you just said
people going around breaking things for
fun I mean one what
one under how to convince people beside
that this is a good thing or was while
considering for some of these agencies I
think it gets hard sometimes to have
this discussion with data like census
data that you know at least by now
because Germany had such a terrible
census history and unsuccessful longer
census you know are also only a small
pieces of information in it to to convey
sort of the harm or the risk that could
happen but I do think one strategy to
launch that discussion will
progressively would be to talk about
from level data from industry they've
updated their and that was one of York's
projects on grading since I think data
files was because they're it's like
everyone sees the risk immediately and
and in there we have a huge non-response
at least in in Germany because these
surveys are not really mandatory or
never enforced and therefore basically
voluntary and they have chair of a
response rates I mean you know fifteen
twenty thirty percent you know and in if
if there if the general perception would
change that my firm level data are safe
then who knows maybe we would indeed get
more response right that that would be
an interesting
I was going to change the subject
do you want to write ahead target the
comment was made earlier about issues of
allocating privacy budget and kind of
picking winners and losers and I'm
wondering is there anything isn't that
something that we've been doing for
years it's just being done in advance
when you design the collection and
design them in the design methodology
decision but is it really any different
so you mentioned that in your talk I
believe John I heard you say that I
think you're absolutely right if it is a
survey based data collection there are a
lot of decision going on and you know in
unsafe neighborhoods it's much harder to
convince interviewers to make twenty
contact attempts as it is in safe
neighborhoods right I mean there is
there's a lot of you know things going
on differentially I mean in a different
different way you know as a function of
your outcomes of interest or you know
different winners and losers so I think
on those data yes from the European
perspective it really is much more about
the the release and the use case for
administrative data and they I would say
much less sewn right because the the
collection system for administrative
data so data that are a byproduct of
administrative processes just I am
employed and therefore my employer has
to report to the Social Security system
my wage and start date and end date in
those kind of data they are they are
much more uniform in the way they are
collected in a report is there not a
decision being made that certain things
need to be reported there and you know
that there's presumably some cost
associated with reporting those some
things I can see going directly to you
know
have to a pose for taxation but others
Pro clearly so some requirements because
of the plain use of these industry
around um unfortunately not in the u.s.
race ethnicity that's part of the OMB
standard but other than that brokers
it's that's a big trouble that actually
all the statistical agencies now face so
everyone would like to use more of the
administrative data but but there the
records are often sparse in the sense
that what's of interest from a
statistical energy point of view or from
researcher than then uses those product
is it's they often too sparse and and
and it's hard to impossible to get
additional records on file I mean I know
this one case in Germany where we try to
get part-time like full-time part-time
employment as part of the record system
you know it feels like decades MIT
they're all decades for this one
variable you know so so it really is
usually just what's necessary for the
administrative process and with in the
context of GDP are that's actually even
more likely to be the case because again
it's so use case driven what you're even
allowed to collect
so I'd like to follow up on what your
said about the Scandinavian attitudes
toward privacy why are the names deleted
why are we just trying to they still
have governed by the EU legislation and
they have completely open registers you
don't even need a survey so it's even
the case I think so first of all what
they do which is interesting which would
not be possible in Germany so you they
have a unique ID that you get when
you're born and then they link
everything all the time all these
different administrative sources are all
linked and it's it's really true that
you can even you can ask for information
even for specific persons if you want
it's not really like you know they
necessarily I mean it's I don't know if
they would give you a whole data set
with all the names attached to it but
you know if you want to know find out
about something about someone you can
ask for that pull the data analyst is
which also brings up the question of how
you get certified to be a researcher or
this is actually independent of being a
researcher so these research regulations
this is specific for Germany but it's
going to Naevia
this is no it's not true that arbitrary
people could get this information that's
right they get information from a
register from the register yeah yeah
that's a survey data they is
nobody but the register data as super
rich I mean this is the your school
records you you know I mean any any
record throughout your life so and there
anyone can get back so in particular our
president couldn't have his school
report suppressed from this so I think
you have to be a citizen yeah I mean to
get a data system I didn't say it was
that made it harder especially if you
design a research proposal that makes
large-scale statistical use of these
things there are still hoops to jump
through
curious are there distinctions between
the various Scandinavian countries or
they're all the same giggles good
question I don't know how oh I mean I
can't
I only know that in general the
Scandinavians are much more relaxed
about the data and they share that but
you know in terms of Iceland counts as
part of Scandinavia and like the
interest of Iceland for genetic
researchers with their population
I think you're right we shouldn't
generalize by just saying skin and have
you except to the extent that the
registers have existed in the small of
the Scandinavian countries for quite
some time I have read discussions about
the Swedish registers and I have
participated in analysis of Norwegian
registers probably most people in the
room know about national jealousy day in
Finland which is when you can ask for
the tax return of anybody in the country
and it is shown to you so this we're not
making this up Cynthia but but but but
there is heterogeneity and the extent to
which these can be used for large-scale
statistical purposes of other things
the United Kingdom is more similar I
think to the the United States in the
sense that we don't have registers and
we have a traditional census like you
know I was on a task force for these
this EU table builder which I said is
was based on every member state having
to produce a 150 very big
multi-dimensional hyper cubes and and it
was very interesting sitting around a
table because the ONS said well you know
I'm you're gonna get 150 hyper cubes
with the record swapping and Italy said
we will give them to you but we're gonna
round all the values in Estonia said
here they are you know so it was so now
I'm then maybe some but one country said
we're going to suppress all the Dutch
we're going to suppress all the cells so
basically just get the margins and how
they're actually reconciling this table
builder as as to me as a so I actually
got kicked off the task force because I
said we don't need to touch these hyper
cubes keep it behind your firewalls and
then when you query the table will
protect the table net that you know
round or add the noise or prama and so I
got but no EU country would agree to
actually release you know any tables
that have not been perturbed to the to
Eurostat so and now they're talking
about again doing having a more
consistent agenda and they are looking
at post randomization and they are
looking at perturbing the zeros so if we
heard a little bit of that at the PSD
conference and of course I'll be a
seeing what's happening there for the
next census
maybe one other thing that might be of
interest so we've been working with you
know state and city agencies to for them
to share their confidential micro data
for analysis and and I I mean I feel
like this this they're these two two
waves right I mean those that try to
unlock these data and push for open data
and open access and solutions to do that
similar tools a little what you
mentioned but then the others that that
push for enclaves and more controlled
environments right and I mean it is it's
not for me to tell you know what what
could be the more successful strategy to
unlock the data and allow more users or
more bottom line use let's put it this
way whether it would be to convince them
of you know releasing the micro data in
the open with the privacy budget in
particular or whether it would be an
investment in a more controlled
environment with basically similar
stories you table Billa some control
perturbation at the end right and so
five because of this linkage many of
these reported similar statutory
regulations as I've heard from the
Germans because it is so often tied to
our data can only be used if it is
useful to x-gen data generating process
that route in the data center while it's
still hot seems still more logical
because then you you know who wants to
do what with the data and you can
basically make the argument this is
helping us whereas the to move towards
the open data environment then you lose
that piece but but there is legislation
or you know move also within Europe to
have more open data and
accessible data and sort of these
methods help in that in that direction
and so to me this is not conflicting
with the notion of food researchers and
our DC's they're still always going to
be that route but we also have to think
about other statistical agencies
collecting too much data and B is it
like a whiplash effect because whenever
you are severe day then they look at
Google panic so much so shouldn't we be
collecting a lot of data so I mean I can
maybe talk a little bit about that
I think currently the lot of investments
and research at least at the statistical
agencies I know about go exactly in that
direction that they say you know what
can we replace by just collecting data
that's already lying around anywhere or
any way right we don't need to collect
all that data ourselves because there's
so much data available now in all the
places and and this is no longer
required so they are looking for ways to
get alternative data sources the
question of course is always the
question of data quality and that you
it's hard to be sure what the quality of
the data is that you these the so called
found data that you that you can extract
I think that is something where a lot of
yeah I think this is a movement where
it's currently not clear where this will
end and because at least I I think the
statistical agencies are really looking
into these opportunities trying to to
get this information but it's still this
skepticism about the quality and there
so there's a trade-off there and yeah
it's a question how good is will the
quality be that they can get from also
know
sources and of course they will depend
then on these alternative sources which
can be problematic this is going back
just to the proof though the previous
exception your mark is mentioning about
the cities and state and then once that
just actually turned to John and find
out it yeah whether you have any view on
what's happening outside statistical
agency of us but in government Tories
what for example before Simpson
Garfinkel came to the Census Bureau one
of the last things he did at NIST was
producing this you know document on D
identifying government data sets which
was motivated not just by what the
problem confronted by statistical
agencies yeah so I have some limited
knowledge of what's going on in the rest
of government and I know that the
agencies are struggling to classify
their data as human related and
therefore I need to worry about the
identification versus not and they have
discovered that it's a continuum and and
and that this collegian C's have
expertise in a very narrow set of
activities relative to what most
government agencies generate data on so
that that's going to be a very slow
process on there will be great benefits
and certainly some mistakes made along
the way
one thing I did want to respond to
Ashwin by saying that it statistical
agencies have been very slow to
acknowledge that their role as the
primary manufacturer of statistical
information in their societies was
superseded we don't know exactly when
the lines crossed but the the one the
one where the external sources are the
primary source is exponential and it
crossed the necessarily linear survey
world inside disk Layton sees probably
sometime in the 2000s but now the the
external line is so far above where
statistical agency is that they really
can't even comprehend I had it I had an
IT specialist and since it's a very good
one say oh we really got to worry about
moving this to the card we have almost a
half a petabyte of data I'm pretty sure
Google generates that in a few seconds
right now it's just that is that the
scale of the amount of digital
information has not sunk in the
statistical agencies themselves are not
equipped to bring in specialists who can
interact effectively with this world
just building the cloud environment to
do our disclosure limitation experiments
on you know how long it took it took it
took a year to get all the permissions
in place before we could turn on the dan
came told me what he needed any left and
we were almost there so so I think
that's it that is a really big issue
redesigning the idea of producing
statistics in the national interest but
from sources that are largely not
designed by the statisticians inside
those agencies is a much bigger sea
change than disclosure limitation but
it's happening at the same time and I
meant you know in for the long efforts
that has been done the US Federal
Statistical system but just like John
said we shouldn't talk about
Scandinavian countries all in one batch
that would be true for statistical
I mean if it's important in those
conversations to be clear in which
country we are talking about right
because that's very different whether
you are an agency that by and large
collects a bunch of administrative data
and creates statistics out of that or
whether it's all survey based and but
what is true all of them you know the
the heavy admin record based systems as
well as the server based system they all
look now to external third-party data
and what could we learn from all the
additional data
that's the community they bought I mean
I could be wrong and proud to make an
else better event in my interaction with
number of social and behavioral
scientists and you know clinical people
who build clinical data
I think there's one group that we can
forget those are the actual researchers
who are still very actively collecting
data themselves they are designing
they're running surveys and the surveys
their quote the data they're collecting
based on the surveys they are designing
and running they may also be interested
in interacting but all the data that the
government agencies that are collecting
interest survey but then there's this
all poll additional a section of a basic
data availability and it's not like
everyone is starting just and saying
we're just going to use all the data
available there's still a lot of ongoing
efforts on their own personalized kind
of data collections for very specific
purposes and I think there is a great
need from my perspective as much as
there is for the large government
agencies large serving organizations to
help in how we communicate about the
privacy protection methods and the right
analysis to do that as much so to do
them with witness researchers who are
collecting data themselves because
they're trying to figure out data
repositories within their libraries
libraries are talking a lot about these
issues and that nobody really knows what
they're doing they want
and there's great I think boiler engine
is there and then me right I think you
you point to two interesting pieces
there that I feel like might spur some
research ideas or you know looking for
gaps you're absolutely right you know
similar to what York said the earlier
even the agencies might never get there
that all of the information products
they have to deliver can be done by our
existing sources but but certainly they
are tailored research questions that
can't be answered with them without a
doubt but what what what you point to I
think is an interesting question with
respect to sort of privacy budget
allocation and what-have-you is that
increasingly these data shall be linked
to at some point in the future will be
linked to the more standard routine
collect the data whether it's through
administrative sources or larger
statistical agency efforts and it's not
clear to me how you know how this
community thinks about that right
because it's you know some of that
research in fact it is encouraged you
know that this linkage happens because
then you can you know reduce the burden
and all the arguments that you know well
and but but that that has been a trend
absolutely and and it probably will be
important to think that through totally
second your comment on more education
needed for them on privacy but that
which are government agencies or
basically saying well you do have to
share your data once you collect it and
in some cases maybe three years you wait
in some cases you're gonna have to do it
right away and make it available right
so there are additional actors perturb
you for data sharing even if you even if
I'm the one who collected a that and I'm
not linking it to anything that any
product the census is providing or any
other government agencies some other
person who will end up using my data may
right so that that's a area that and
again if the tools are not there I mean
in my conversations with those
individuals
and groups they're desperate
I want to make one more point before we
close I think one in terms of sort of
sea change events in in in the space at
least year citizen offices might be the
current push to geocode all the data
they have I mean even that but I mean
this happens the the major records and I
mean everyone is pushing they discovered
your location and what that would mean
for linkage and they feel like this is
much better than linking via name and
birthday or whatever have you and right
now they're doing that sort of
individually and but but I can see this
coming you know that that will will
likely change the discussion quite a bit
and so the next time
does anybody want to raise any other
coins it's not I want to thank our
panelists very much
[Applause]
[Music]